(Nice, Very Nice)
We're in the middle of shooting,
Annie Leibovit came out to take her stills
(Excellent, very nice to meet you)
Annie was
in a way
sort of our first audience
And so
and so just having
someone elses eyes
taking this in for the first time
I love it, it was really cool.
With Rian,
With the cast,
And with the audience,
we all get to discover who
these characters are
Everything is being shifted in the opposite way
to what the audience expected after seven
The enthusiasm and how much ownership
they have taken
has really been exciting
I get to be a part of this amazing story
and to be on a set with the most
incredible crew,
It's wonderful.
It's so much different in many ways than the other episodes
and yet,
I think it' very satisfying
in delivering what the fans want to see.
I cannot wait for people to get a glimpse
of the stuff we are doing.
New Star Wars The Last Jedi, let's break it down
you may have also spotted
that we got a bunch of new characters in that footage
so that's Canto Bite casino planet
that you may have heard about
that Laura Dern's character shows up
and that Finn and Rose's character get involved with
so I'll explain that at the end of the video
there's a whole bunch of stuff to get through
as we're headed towards summer we're gunna start seeing a lot more Last Jedi stuff dropping
so be sure to subscribe to get everything if you're brand new to the channel
and let me know what kind of Star Wars videos you want me to do
this is all part of a Vanity Fair photo shoot
you may remember they did the same thing last year
before the force awakens
where we got our first look at Kylo Ren
without his helmet on
but let's start with the big stuff first
Kylo ren, Phasma with her helmet off
and everybody is wearing evil person capes
what would team dark-side be without space capes
one of my favourite costumes from last year was Krennics one
because it's white so it invokes a lot of the imagery of the grand admiral,
even though he didn't have one
but it just says so much about a character when they wear a cape
because it's not common to wear a cape in the Empire
you notice that most of them just walk around in there normal uniforms
but I did see that a lot of people
were surprised that Phasma is back
so if you didn't know
they actually gave assurances after Episode 7 came out
and she had a very brief appearance that she would be much bigger in episode 8
they didn't say exactly what her role would be
but we saw her in the trailer and it looked like she was wrecking the resistance
and Rian Johnson did say
that when the movie picks up
they are doubling down, like eve though they lost the Star Killer base,
there's more chaos than ever because they destroyed a large portion of the New Republic
but the galaxy is huge and just because they blew up a couple of those planets
doesn't mean they completely destroyed everything that was the new Republic
they don't control everything
so they're scrambling for territory at the beginning of the movie
and evil space games aside, there's not that many costume changes
Phasma's wearing the same armour,
she got throw down a garbage shoot so the armour's probably gotten a new polish that's about it
Kylo Rens costumes is a little bit different
his make-up is probably the biggest change
just that big scar that's no longer running down the bridge of his nose
which I think we can all agree is a good choice by Rian Johnson
you look at here and you're like, ye that was definitely weird
that would be strange to walk around staring at that for two hours in a movie
just that look on Phasma's face is so awesome
and I'm really hoping that Kylo Ren goes full tantrum
and kills General Hux
because they have this nice rivalry that going on
but for all of his faults, if he has the grit to kill Han Solo, his father,
then what's killing another Imperial General
It's just another Darth Vader moment, just killing every officer that displeases him
so hopefully we'll se something like that in Episode 8
I love this footage of Adam Driver behind the scenes swinging the lightsaber around
does that not remind you of Lightsaber Kid from way way back on the internet
that was one of the first big meme's
that was so hilarious
so it's just funny to laugh about that
and the just laugh about Kylo Ren just a little bit too
maybe he can redeem himself in Last Jedi
I expect him to show up in the next trailer too in a much bigger way.
Luke and Rey aren't that different
there were a lot of people remarking how like the colour brown is so important in a lot of these photos
whereas the colour red, from the trailers, seems much more important
so some of the colour choices seem a little weird but I think that's just meant to invoke the Jedi browns
but if you look down here you can see Luke has covered up his metal hand with a brown glove
that's probably just for practicality because they have to use special effects ever time they have is hand on screen
so it's just easier for him to put the glove on so he doesn't have to wear any special prosthetics
this is just the same costume that Rey was wearing at the end of episode 7
we know that she changes into this at some point.
They are a couple of character's that get costume changes, we go a preview for Rey and Kylo Ren
Poe finally found himself a new jacket, that's the new character Rose over there
she and Finn go on an adventure together, I don't know if Poe is gunna be a part of that
but John Boyega was hyping up a lot of Finn adventure with the Rose character
who kind of gets swept up in things
we see him in the Bacta Suit here, this is obviously very early in the movie
this scene here looks like the First Order raiding the Resistance base
because it seems like things only go from
bad to worse
and the tone of the movie is much darker
so if you though the Resistance was a fraction of the size of the Rebellion it's gunna be getting even smaller
they just wonna really really make them feel like underdogs
so you guys can let me know what you think about them scaling down the galactic conflict
so during the original trilogy you have like a really big Rebellion fleet against a HUGE Imperial fleet
now they've scaled that way back, the First Order has a large fleet but it's not nearly as large as the original Empires fleet
in all thes ships you're seeing here, it's pretty much the Resistance fleet
so everything's been scaled way down and I think it makes it a little bit more personal
a little bit more of a dog fight.
The Canto Bight's stuff all looks fantastic
so most of what you've seen on the New Republic so far is in that really quick shot before they blow those planets up
And then with the resistance characters, General Leia, who wears very Spartan clothing
you know, she's very simple, she doesn't get dressed up as much as she did before the destruction of Alderaan
so Lauren Durn's character is sort of the counter point to that, she's a really big figure in the New Republic
but a lot of her design language, the way she dressed is more influenced by the prequel trilogy
than say, the original trilogy, which informs more of the design around Leia's character
like the places where she is, like you can see them here in this resistance base here looks like it's underground
and then you have the Canto Bight's stuff, which is just like the height of opulence
Benicio Del Toro's character does not appear in any of this footage here
but he does appear in this picture
he's a big Canto Bight character, he's sort of the Lando Calrissian of that planet
and for those who are asking Billy Dee Williams did confirm that he was no where in Last Jedi
so if he's going to appear in any of the movies it's going to have to be Episode 9
but of all this Canto Bight's stuff, the funniest thing that people have been talking about
is this tiny little alien here, they're like, he's probably the richest person on the planet
but he looks like he's plant based, they haven't said anything about who he is
he's just a new character they created for this
so let me know what you guys think about this little creature here but obviously he's intelligent he's just incredibly small.
but Resistance commander, General Leia,
so she's wearing this giant blowing brown robe, we've seen a couple different costumes that she's in
and obviously in the trailer she's in  slightly different version of this too staring at this blue hollo display of the galaxy.
There are a couple of costume editions that we haven't see her wearing before
she wasn't wearing a lot of jewellery when we saw her during episode 7
so some of this could be in memorial for Han Solo or it could just be for this photoshoot that they did
but like I said, most of this stuff where they're shooting her here is in resistance base underground looking places
and they have all these picture with her with Luke, that could be when they share scenes together
they do actually have scenes together in the movie but I don't know how much it's going to be
so they will be extra special, just a really good way to pay memorial to Carrie Fisher.
But a lot of these scenes here with them all sitting together, like you see Rey behind the scenes talking o Poe Finn...
that might just be from this photoshoot, that doesn't mean they necessarily share scenes together
because even though the movie is taking a lot of left turns from Empire plot
people are like, okay it's the middle movie it's going to feel like Empire,
there are a lot of things that are similar to empire, one of the biggest things I that everyone is split up
so like, Luke was not with Han and Leia for most of Empire Strikes Back
but a lot of you were asking me about the big news about them supposedly having some earth shattering reveal
that's going to happen during episode 8
and people were wandering what that was, is it going to be Rey's parents,
is it going to be something else, really I don't think it's that complicated
I think all it is just the revelation that Whills are a real thing
they haven't really invoked them in the films that much
they come into play with the guardians of the Whills during Rogue One
but that's really the beginning of them setting up the new cannon of the force, the things that they are adding to it
so obviously they're not throwing out a lot of the stuff that George Lucas set up,
that's all still canon from the original films, from Rebels, even Clone Wars is still canon
so everything you've learned about the force from those things is still good
but we talked abut the concept of the journal of the Whills and the idea that there's some greater truth to the force that's been lost over time
and everyone's searching for the original Jedi temple so that they can find this book and learn what the truth of things are
that's probably why Luke Skywalker so hot on ending the Jedi order once and for all
not that he wants to end Jedi, he just sound like he's grown very disillusioned with their practises
and their beliefs and he wants to find some new path
but I posted that interview video where Rian Johnson stops himself from spoiling a big part of the movie
a big reveal about Rey identity, that probably gets into what a lot of the big reveal is
like, ow my god the Whills are a thing, what is the journal of the Whills, what does it say
what is the real truth of the force
and then they'll leave a lot of the job of explaining that to Episode 9
just like you learn all about Luke Skywalker's father being Darth Vader during Empire
but you really don't learn what that means and explore the deeper context until you get to Jedi
but leave all your requests for Star Wars bonus videos, if there's an concepts you guys want me to do
and I wouldn't be surprised if they attach another trailer to Spider-Man Homecoming this summer
because that's probably when they're going to drop another Thor trailer
Disney really likes to group all their trailers together for big releases so I wouldn't expect new footage at least until then
but while you wait for everything you can click here for that interview video where they preview what's going on during the movie
and you can click here for my trailer breakdown.
Thank you so much for watching, let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight.